foreign
how does this sound
can you guys hear me
all right I think I'm too loud
all right
waiting for Dart
but I figured we'd go live and have a
chat
am I too loud
you guys got to keep in mind too there's
other people that like me a little
louder maybe some of you should like
lower it
sound Perfect Dude okay let me mute
myself then
what's going on you guys
gaming out here Lord added coming at you
with another attic show and then bam
Berg and he's in here we're already live
dirt ah what's up man what's going on
dirt I I went live a little early to
address the community
oh it's all good man what's what's
popping what's what's popping it's
pretty good man we we this is a little
bit of the uh the after show
the alpha show the the the the before
show oh no oh the the pre-show
ah man crazy day bro
yeah uh I was just going to solo dolo it
but she was like I'm I'm good I'm like
okay good yeah now it's all good man
because I was you know because I wasn't
sure if I was on because I didn't go to
work today I had some stuff going on
um and I wasn't sure I was gonna be able
to make it but earlier today I said oh I
can I should be able to make it so
yeah we we got a crazy show for you guys
man
you guys have no idea
uh that that Xbox under attack thing
yeah we talking about PlayStation 5 but
it's gonna be real with you
you know that that's a media thing but
I for one
and tired
of stuff and we'll get to that later on
because um you know people seem to not
like me making acquisition videos we'll
we'll get more into it later like I
think there's a root of an issue of why
people don't like me making acquisition
videos but we'll get to that later
what's going on you guys this attic here
welcome to another added show we talk
about the past present future game I got
my calls with me sir green what's going
on there what's up y'all
how everybody doing today
doing pretty good man pretty good so
what you've been playing
you know damn well what I've been
playing I don't know why you even asked
that question
now I'll be playing Starfield and um
a little bit of NBA 2K 24.
that's
been it right now those the two games
I've been playing
yeah I where I played so much at
Starfield like during the review process
I actually I've like moved on to other
games I'm still playing it yeah I
actually got like a crazy I don't know
if you saw the clip I put of my ship
that I'm currently rocking with right
now I didn't actually no oh you should
go on my Twitter right now and and look
at what these people try to do man they
came at me dirt like four on one
and I killed them all but one and I made
an example of that [__]
okay let me check it out yeah so you
know appreciate everyone for coming
through here man you know uh attic show
has been growing every week we had like
5 300 views last week get like three to
four hundred live viewers like we
growing man we grow there you go brother
but you know we had a show that had like
25 000.
who did this us us are you talking about
iron Lords no no us really us
wow yeah iops like doing around that
every week now for them that's that's
what you don't bro so yo
we got we got a good show for you guys
man we're going to talk about Xbox
credit cards and I had to put in
parentheses haha beside it uh we talked
about star filled under attack by media
and Playstation Fanboys and then we were
talking about star filled reviews man
Starkville reviews we got a two dollar
super trap from Raiden blade we didn't
start this review BS but we will end it
I respect that man I respect that yeah
man hey man you know yeah shout out to
the homie Raiden blade because he's
right
yeah so let's let's get to the to the
little crummies the crummies that we're
gonna be talking about today today we're
going to be talking about the
credit card that Xbox has started have
you seen this dirt yeah
you know you know it's funny I made a
video about it because uh I thought it
was interesting you know Xbox is getting
into the credit card uh scenario
you would think
that I was talking about something else
because nobody watched it
the worst video
produced like you wise in like three
months
yeah man sometimes there's topics like
there's some topics I would want to do a
video about but I'll say nah the homies
ain't gonna want to see it so yeah I
think I'm going to start like picking
because I thought it was interesting but
apparently you guys didn't and I respect
that I respect that man I respect that
yeah I don't think most people really
give a damn you know what I'm saying
yeah it's like it's like 33 interest
it's ridiculous bro it's ridiculous I
was like no way in hell as much as I
love Xbox no no
I think the only okay so first off it
doesn't have an annual fee which that is
a big plus over a lot of other cards uh
because you know a lot of those earlier
cards that give you annual fees because
they know a lot of those cards are like
credit building cards right so they're
gonna get you with that annual fee right
I have a friend right now it is his most
it's his longest credit line one with an
annual fee it's because that's like his
first credit card right but they CR they
penalize you if you get rid of
your your longest credit form so he
still pays that annual fee every year
yeah because it will drop his credit
score if he if he gets rid of it yeah so
the thing I just interesting the most
about this is like
they revolved around this thing like you
know some credit cards like I have a
Discover card that gives you a uh cash
back and uh this card doesn't give you
cashback gives you Xbox back you get
your Xbox
the Xbox points of what Xbox Rewards
what did they give you back I think I I
it's like a combination of anything on
the store now what I will say is if you
are responsible with credit cards uh
like extremely responsible like like
responsible and
smart where you you know you you only
pay what you have this isn't a card that
you want to use for like long-term stuff
like you guys an emergency happen gotta
drop it on the credit card but I could
see you using this for like you know
daily stuff that you know you're gonna
pay back at the end of the week
yeah that's the same thing yeah because
with this you are at least like let's
say you have another credit card first
off I don't recommend getting it there's
a thousand different cards that's better
than this one yeah but if you want it in
your wallet this is Xbox in your
Gamertag I guess but you know that's not
being responsible either just to get a
card because it's got Xbox on the front
of it but what I will say is like they
give you like five percent more uh if
you you get five percent if you buy Xbox
stuff with it and then it's like you get
if you buy
if you buy like doordash and stuff with
it so like they are literally rewarding
you for being a gamer like a legit gamer
but it's like I said
I just don't recommend it because I feel
like there's better cards yeah there
there's plenty of better cards because
when I saw the apis oh snap no I'm good
but it's like I said if if you are
responsible
and you know you want to get it for some
weird reason I guess but it's just like
I I think
this is definitely not a car now maybe
it's one of those low score credit score
cards where it's like the threshold like
around like six to six fifty
where you know you're in that part where
you can't get like the good good cards
like you know uh Discover Cards um uh
what's the one with the people on it
like the Platinum cards that are clear
yeah they only give the good good credit
people right uh like if you can't get
stuff like that then maybe this is if
it's good in a good place where
it's right above building credit but
right below good good good credit then
maybe this is a good option for you just
depends on where this is and how and
when they're going to start accepting it
right yeah
it's cool but
I'm good on that yeah there's there's
way better cars man like I would
recommend Kitty
I'd recommend getting an Amazon card
over this a a Walmart credit card over
there yeah yeah yeah
yeah but I am good so we're gonna move
on to that because I didn't think we we
would talk about that long
you know what we're going to talk about
we're going to talk about Borderlands
for sale did you see the gearbox is
really be for sale yeah man I saw people
talking about
whether or not it would be a good
purchase for Xbox so first thing I want
to talk about is
your interpretation of the game being
for sale of the call of the studio being
for sale it was like 1.2 billion dollars
or something like that and
do you think this is a good buy for
Microsoft if the price was better or do
you think even if price was good that
they just don't need it I'm kind of
curious to hear your opinion on that
well I'm not a fan
but if the price was much better 1.2
billion is way too much way too much up
there what Tony paid for uh for bungee
yeah yeah it's it's way too much
um if the price was much lower I think
the Borderlands franchise would be I
guess
valuable but to be honest with you add
it I don't I'm not a fan at all
um I don't think Xbox should even look
in that direction to be honest with you
to be honest that's my opinion I I don't
think they should even look in that
direction there's better Studios better
franchises I mean I mean I bought a
lenses a pretty big franchise but I
think they should look else elsewhere
after the APK deal is over with
do you think that
okay let's say that they get it on like
a flash sale
like like like what what embrace your
group paid for Crystal Dynamics yeah for
like 300 million that's a million yeah
that's that's a little different I mean
at that point anything north of 500
million for some reason I'm like no yeah
I mean if it's something under that like
you said like like a fire sale
yeah that's that's a possibility because
I think the franchise is valuable enough
um to be and under Xbox first part
Studios but not for like over 500 no
gotta sneeze I'm sorry
yeah I just I personally feel like when
it comes to this this scenario it's like
one of those things where it's like look
Borderlands is a love franchise a lot of
people love it my brother just left it
like he's a huge Borderlands fan and you
know they've been doing the movie right
I think they are Borderlands 3 might
have disappointed some people but I
would still say that the franchise still
got legs and if they can get that for a
good price I would say Borderlands is
definitely worth putting in the yeah in
the ecosystem even if it's just a I
would say you could argue that they
could buy this just for for TV
hmm because Borderlands got a like
really long legs really good
personalities
I feel like if they could get this for
like three four hundred million they'd
be stupid not to like the studio and the
Borderlands IP the Borderlands IP is
probably worth that by itself
[Music]
and imagine like them popping out it's
in Game Pass the next Borderlands is
exclusive look I'm trying to upset
people at this point okay and and I'm
all about Xbox taking pieces off the
PlayStation board all right because I
because because what we about to talk
about here in a second is I made a video
dirt I was like
first off I even said don't buy this
studio if they can't get a good price
Marcel I think that's his name
I don't know oh do you have the uh do
you have the receipt like can you pull
it up or yeah let's let's pull it let's
see let's pull it to see yeah there's
another Nick
that's going around a pony Nick that's
going around the community that's the
total POS
Sibly dude yeah
this dude oh you talking about Nicola or
no no oh yeah oh that's that's the
original Nick Nicola
what are we doing here
this dude
[Laughter]
okay so he brings up he brings up my
tweets yeah of my past videos where a
month ago I made a video talking about
Xbox buying the Lorraine Studios because
of party A3 and then should Xbox buy
Borderlands does it make sense I even
put in the title doesn't make sense
question mark right both of us have
questions marks in the title
what's funny is like
tell me if I'm wrong
dirt I don't know tell me if I'm wrong
are people mad when Xbox content
creators make buy Studios because
this [__] could happen like they're
they're paranoid man they're scared to
death what are we doing here Addie what
are you trying to say attic
you're talking you guys you know you're
talking hypothetically but everybody
know it's possible
look
no offense to that because he ain't
never really done nothing harm to me
uh but I will make videos how I want to
make videos
you know I wake up in the mornings I
check through Twitter I got like six or
seven people I follow on Twitter that I
just scroll through their feed what I
want to talk about today that's all
Borderlands pop up and I'm like you know
what
that's a good video I love acquisition
videos I love them
uh because it's just like a good concept
on whether or not the game works in the
ecosystem could could they benefit
Microsoft in the long run do they make
similar games that actually makes sense
do they strengthen Microsoft's lineups
do they weaken it like there's a lot of
good ways that you can take a video like
that that's why I do them because I feel
like it's actually fun content to make
it's a good discussion
but PlayStation fanboys
they get so scared now
the Lorraine Studios one
PlayStation people wasn't on my ass over
that video it was PC people
they were on me like crazy that
that video
got like
400 000 Impressions
um
it was cool because my video views kept
going up
right but man I was getting roasted dirt
I was good I was getting drugged through
I've seen her trying to grab any any any
structure to man they they had that that
dude from The Evil Within that you have
to stick around that grabs you and just
drives you through the hallways I'm
sitting here trying to grab anything man
I might as well been a character in in
dead by daylight I can't grab nothing it
feels like everything I grabbed just
cuts my fingers and I'm just sitting
here getting dragged up and down this
hallway all day long and then they just
let me go
and I just I just like ran into my
little closet and just shiveled up and
be like I won't mess with the PC Fanboys
again I won't miss the piece of bad boy
and then the next time I make the mat
again
so it's just like
I will make the content I want because
it interests me yeah if you don't like
it don't watch that video I I feel that
like I was interested the Xbox was for
some reason you know I still think it's
funny try to get into the credit card
system
I thought it was a funny thing so I made
a video
I got the the consequences for making a
video on a credit card Xbox it was
called Low ass views
that that that video didn't even get 600
views see what it is you just learned
over the years
um you learn the people that listen to
your channel you learn you know your fan
base I don't like to say fan base
because you know we're not celebrities
or nothing but still yeah can you learn
the people that watch your content what
they like and what they don't like so
there's years where I would do certain
type of content didn't get as many views
then I do another style of content get
more viewers oh okay they don't like
that style
so you know sometimes even if I know
it's gonna flop I'm like I still gotta
do it um
there comes that point where you say
listen I gotta keep it real I gotta do
this I gotta slander Xbox if they do
something wrong
oh yeah
against the anything against Xbox it
will still give views but I get a lot
more hate in the comments section yeah
and it's just like look I got to keep it
real myself I keep it real PlayStation
you know I I tend to like what's funny
is people say attic why do you only make
anti-playstation news you never make
positive PlayStation It's like because
that's that's the PlayStation Channel's
job yeah it's not my fault they don't do
it it's not my fault they only talk
about Xbox I'm glad you said that
because what I've learned what I do when
there's some bad Xbox news
I don't do a dedicated video I usually
talk about it on the podcast one of my
podcasts oh I do a dedicated video Yeah
it depends on how bad it is because last
year when they tried to double the price
of Xbox Live I did do a dedicated video
but
um no I don't do PlayStation positive
PlayStation no that's not what my
channel is
somebody called me Xbox Fanboy the other
day and thought he insulted me
I call myself an Xbox Fanboy so I'm
clearly biased well that's my channel is
what it is no I'm not doing positive
PlayStation article like you said that's
what the pony channels are go to their
channels you want to see it you're not
going to get positive positive
PlayStation stuff for my channel here so
you know how my structure is like blue
beans PlayStation PlayStation marketing
is not good they're also just liars
the one before that say I don't make
much PlayStation content because I know
my people don't care about that naughty
dog will delays Last of Us factions
PlayStation showcases the worst ever
I've seen in years
PlayStation massive showcase reveal and
it's just like look like my audience
don't care they just don't like their
their XBox people uh but you know if
it's big enough on X PlayStation like
I'll I'll review their games
because I feel like games is where uh
you know I definitely are interested you
know news my audience don't care they're
like look it is what it is but games my
audience does care about PlayStation
games yeah see so you so you're learning
your audience bro that's all it is
that's all it is like my audience love
positive Xbox news they love PlayStation
Fanboy slander and they love negative
PlayStation news that's what my audience
likes I'm just being real bro and it's
the PlayStation Fanboys Their audience
like it
so they do it that's what they do and
you have to learn your audience that's
all it is and people say don't tell me
like you said don't tell me how to do my
channel dirt keep that same energy I
ain't keeping nothing because I listen I
will talk about certain things on the
podcast but when it comes to Dedicated
videos I don't want to talk about
certain stuff and I don't care what
people say no dude you ain't being real
it's like I don't give a damn it's like
jrpgs when I make I want Final Fantasy
people will say addict these games on
sale adequate you're wasting your time
addict don't care because attic wants
those games on his platform right I know
I'm talking to myself in the third
person but that's fine because Addie
going to make them videos right
yeah I really do I will have people on
my ass over those Final Fantasy videos
why do you care just buy a PlayStation
I'm not a PlayStation fan if I was a
PlayStation Channel all I would do
it's talk smack on Xbox and never
criticize PlayStation I don't do that
because
people are like well why don't you just
make I want you to buy a place I want
them on my platform
I don't want to buy a PlayStation I buy
a PlayStation for their first party
stuff but all the third party stuff
if PlayStation doesn't own it I want it
on my console because I generally think
that Xbox ecosystem is in a better place
with those games I agree so let's see if
that's okay bro that's okay
let's get these super chats real quick
and then we'll
we'll move on uh
uh we didn't start okay so we already
got that one
um so we got Raiden Blaine with the two
dollar Super Chat uh Xbox should just uh
should just make in Bryce or a second
party partner that'd be crazy
[Laughter]
tell me if Microsoft announced tomorrow
that they like they have some
like huge exclusive like because we know
that they're doing like kind of bad
financially right now Microsoft just
like sprinkled a couple like a couple
hundred million like they gave them like
a couple billion dollars that are like
all your games
they can Game Pass day and day
you they don't have to be exclusive
right but you know maybe sometimes we'll
come over there and we'll look on the on
your little line you know your little uh
uh line that you guys got before these
games maybe we'll snatch one or two of
them this is ours this is mine right but
for the most part I'm Gonna Let You rock
you're gonna let you sell them but they
ain't Game Pass day and day um do you
think that would actually do really well
that would be cool they make a lot of
games
that'll be cool if all of those games
that would be huge for the for the
subscription service man like you said
they don't have to be exclusive they can
still put it on PlayStation
but having those games launched day and
day and Game Pass that will be bidding
man that would be that would be cool
you know more content the better I love
it
all right so let me get this other Super
Chat real quick and I'm sorry you guys
hear that uh
microwave it'll be off in a second all
right so we got we got a five dollar
subscribe from dolo Knights score Enix
says Place PS exclusivity lost up over 2
billion and they may never recover okay
I don't think it was it was word for
word like that but I do have it on the
agenda we are going to talk about that
it's actually the next topic because I
told you I talked about this Final
Fantasy stuff yeah and you know we're
gonna have to like it's gonna be a
little bit
of attacking on the 16 name that Final
Fantasy 16 we're gonna attack that a
little bit right so
we got a five dollar super trap from the
angry therapist MD sorry I'm late to the
show hey dirt I got engaged to Sarah oh
yeah okay
yeah no I think they said like can you
do that on the game oh oh talk about
games
I thought he said he got engaged engaged
he's talking about the Sarah and uh
Starfield you know what's funny I saw in
kids move uh I was looking at one of his
gameplay and he literally in the final
mission something happened in this
Dynamic where he was fighting Sarah
what I don't know how it happened
because it never happened to me wow yeah
so it was interesting you guys got it
like really pay attention the game was
awesome yeah
we got something I'm sorry go ahead we
got a two dollar from the uh from
Nintendo Dawn the otaku I better hear a
Nintendo Direct topic oh no and people
are saying spoils I get it that's a
little bit of spoilies but here's the
thing when it comes to like
a game like that you expect almost all
your companions are probably gonna give
you smoke at any time if you make the
wrong decisions that's how their games
are but I get it I will stay away from
that yeah
all right so let's let's move on to
Square Enix
27 minutes we on the scores so
[Laughter]
it's
Square Enix is
they're like 500 billion or how much was
yeah well I thought it was two billion
let me see
2 billion
with a B
with a B guy it said Square Enix has
lost nearly two billion dollars since
June that's the exact words on IGN with
a B yeah two billion since June
when Final Fantasy 16 launch wow and
they saying they they're not sure if
they can recover at it
oh
you know what I'm saying
Xbox over there they got some money they
got some funny money
yo
I have to really like
imagine how bad
Xbox uh Twitter would be if they bought
Square Enix
wait wake up one day to a big like that
little picture thing with Final Fantasy
Dragon Age folk Stars
yo
I would sometimes I wish I had a button
that I could just type something in and
just see alternate universe and just
live a day in it
it's crazy bro
you know
I saw this story earlier I said wow
um I saw some people still like they
blame it on Avengers with launch stuff a
few years ago at this point uh Gardens
of the Galaxy but I think it's a
concoction the combination of all of the
decisions they've made
um for spoken didn't do well we all know
they're saying the Final Fantasy 16
didn't do well for them you know like
ponies want to yell 3 million copies so
so apparently that wasn't enough for
screen is when the game costs 100 and
100 something million to make
so it seems like some bad decisions or
maybe people are just getting tired of
Final Fantasy franchise with the
exception of of uh part seven
um remake you know that game did well
but I don't know man you know some of
their Western Studios didn't do well
they sold those guys off for pennies I
mean I mean well 300 million obviously
isn't pennies but definitely wasn't the
value they should have gotten for all of
those IP and uh those two great Studios
so they're struggling bro it's
unfortunate
um but sometimes you know your decisions
come back to bite you in the ass man
do you
do you think that Square Enix is
actually legit struggling like like it's
not just like we're not making enough
profit this year like they're legit
struggling I think they're legit
struggling I mean just look at what we
just what I just said what was the last
hit they had was the Final Fantasy 7
remake that's it right yeah wouldn't
that come out 20 what 2019 it's been a
minute
and they've dropped games throughout
these years and all of them have flopped
um they complained about rise of the
Tomb Raider they complained about Shadow
of the Tomb Raider The Avengers it's
like every AAA game they made
they did not do well
now Final Fantasy like 14 might be very
profitable but that's been around since
2013 and I mean it must not be moving
the needle it's was it was Elder being
published
for them yeah I bet you when elderly
came out because I knew they probably
thought Ellen ring was going to catch
some some good vibes but I bet you bam
Namco never thought it would catch the
wave it did
hmm
yeah so I bet you when they looked at
that
they're like
oh we we rolling and dope
I'm kind of curious how much money that
made
I don't know man but uh finally found me
but screenings I I do believe they're
struggling at it I really do
I think this is not them cap and I think
they're struggling
do you think about bro they were
desperate enough to talk to Xbox and do
a deal with Xbox
they have me rocked out with Xbox in
years do you think that
it's struggling enough where they get
bought
yeah I mean I definitely think they're
probably most likely looking to sell
now the question is who's going to buy a
man for how much
that's the question
but I do think they will they will
probably love to be acquired right now
that's the one and only
it would be interesting man I think
that's first off let's
let's talk about the elephant in the
room all right
okay at the end of the day
Final Fantasy 16
it just wasn't a good game to me
um
um and keep in mind you know people sit
there all addict are you really a fan
yeah I'm a fan I've played I've played
probably more final fantas than the
average person by phone
I've played Final Fantasy
seven I played the remake
a hundred percent at seven I played
eight played nine played ten I even
tried 14.
I'd be 12. and that what I say a played
I beat I beat 12
I beat uh I didn't be 13 because I
thought that's where the franchise
started falling downhill for me
um I beat 15.
I I dropped 16.
what's up so you just dropped it like
how many hours did you I dropped it like
it was hot
how many hours did you put into it
just estimating you know it's guessing
I fought a couple here's the thing like
I thought a couple of the elons or elons
or whatever they're called they're
they're cool they are I I do think
they're overblown people oh this is so
cool
it's literally qtes and go like going up
and down half the time like left to
right up down
you're a fake Final Fantasy fan okay
Nintendo domedia talk normally I don't
address messages that aren't that aren't
lit up
but we're gonna address you
addict you're a fake fan Final Fantasy
was a good game final fantastic was
horrible
16 was a better game than 13.
13 was the one well they had the black
guy with the afro that was like yeah
that Top Line yeah yeah so 13. and his
character wasn't that bad I think his
name was like something with S I can't
remember his name yeah but not I
actually played a lot of 13 I just never
beat it
that's the thing I never beat it
it's just like
at the end of the day man
16 just didn't feel like a Final Fantasy
game
it felt like
something different and I could never
explain to you what I mean by that I
even played Final Fantasy Tactics I beat
tactics tactics advance
uh I beat Texas Advanced too I play a
game final fantasy fans I ever heard of
and it's just like I beat Kingdom Hearts
all of them
all right
just it lost me man okay so let me
actually this addict as a fan
when the Final Fantasy franchise went
action
do you think that was the beginning of
the end
I think that's when the quality started
going downhill and I feel like they
started pushing more and more that
direction and you know
13 clearly had success because they
spawned two horrible sequels uh so I get
it you know that
they
they're okay games but they're not what
their former glory was and the
Metacritic score shows it you know they
haven't hit a 90 since they did it
I think I think I don't even think did
Final Fantasy VII remake get a 90
because that's the closest game that yes
I beat Crystal Chronicles what now
oh I beat Crystal cross I bet you didn't
expect that one the GameCube version I
beat
I don't think there's a crystal
Chronicles tooth there was I didn't beat
that yeah the Metacritic for Final
Fantasy
seven remake was 87.
yeah so if you look at Final Fantasy
games they are
they're not there anymore
um you know look up Final Fantasy 12.
12. gotcha I I for the PS2
it's probably high 80s early 90s it
might be the last 90s game
Final Fantasy 12 for the PS2 is
okay come up 92.
I look up 10.
for the PS2 and that's the last one I'll
have you look up
10 is I don't know
PS2 I actually bought that one 92. okay
now one more look up 13. okay
13.
13 for the PS3
83. one second uh you keep to
Interchange someone's talking at my door
damn they knocking a long time ain't
they
like yeah punk addict bring your punk
ass to the door
now so um yeah man it's you know it's
pretty messed up that Final Fantasy I'm
sorry that screen is isn't doing all
that but hey man
it is what it is
so people can sit there they can say
what they want
the numbers show maybe maybe these sell
better I don't know uh
squirting experimentally doing the
credit so I don't know about that either
but you know all I know is they ain't
had a 90 plus Metacritic since they went
to this
um
so people can sit there obviously do
what Dragon Quest did Dragon Quest 11
that was the first Dragon Quest I ever
played I was such a final fantasy fan I
hated on that game for no reason that's
besides the fact so Dragon Quest 11 was
the first game I played of Dragon Quest
that sucker lets you choose between
action and turn base that's nice
they they they respect both people yeah
that's cool to have the option you know
like Starfield ain't like but there's
the game to give you the option third or
first
um hey Dan ataku the taco
he made a good point I just remember
Final Fantasy 13 was the first Final
Fantasy game the launch on Xbox
it's like they're sabotaging asleep
he's right about that because I remember
I remember at that time
Square enemies and like I think some of
the Japanese developers could not ignore
Xbox anymore because in the states Xbox
was absolutely Xbox 360 was destroying
the PS3 and the PS3 did not get off to a
good start so they had to put their
games on Xbox
that was the first one I remember
because I remember the E3 was creating
this game on stage
what it just
to me when it comes to Final Fantasy I
know we won't talk about this much long
it is what it is at this point you know
if
if they choose not to see what's in
front of them you know they keep locking
their games out of PlayStation and
clearly you know of course they're
probably making profit let's let's keep
it real here uh they're always
overestimating what their franchises are
realistically worth it's probably a
reason that that Square Enix hasn't been
bought because they probably value
themselves at like 30 40 billion dollars
man Final Fantasy with 15 by itself
that's probably why they ain't sold to
anyone you know they're realistically
worth probably like seven to eight
billion and they're like every time
someone comes down and have a
conversation we want 30.
what do you mean 30. if you want us
you gotta pay for us well we don't want
you that bad
so I mean
do you think that if these get do you
think it's just a fatigue and no one
likes Final Fantasy games anymore or
screens games in general or do you think
it's because they do these exclusivity
deals and it limits how many they can
actually sell
oh man that's a good question there
might be
um there might be a combination of
things there might be a combination of
people are tired of the franchise or
they didn't like the new direction of
the franchise it can be there's a whole
new
excuse me audience
that that's not that I don't care about
the Final Fantasy like they used to you
know there's only a few uh franchises
that last for years and still is popular
like maybe the Nintendo franchises Mario
Zelda GTA even Halo isn't as popular as
it used to be so maybe Final Fantasy
just isn't as popular as it used to be
babe someone in the chats damn this dude
living the dream got some tacos and
kisses
oh snap
so I mean I I agree I I think that these
games could definitely sell better uh
you know put them on PC switch I think
they should put it on PC day one if they
put all these on day one I think it
would sell better now people in this sit
there say you know it's because it's not
on Xbox calm yourself okay yeah I will
say that you start to nurture these
games have them on the platform for long
amounts of times and not just pick when
you want to drop them Xbox will
eventually start selling more a lot more
uh but you know until we see that day I
I don't I don't blame people
for not buying
Final Fantasy on Xbox because you're not
guaranteed anything you know even people
sit there and say you got to support it
no
don't have the illusion that if you
support Final Fantasy on Xbox you'll see
scoring X Games because
clearly octopath traveler Microsoft
dropped the back and I actually was told
buying closed doors all talked about
travel exceeded expectations on Xbox
sales wise not Game Pass wise sales wise
and that game sequel still didn't come
on the platform yeah but the secret
didn't do as well either though right
and I've been told that it was better
hmm
which sucks man sucks well let's let's
move on man uh I know you guys don't
want to talk look we know what you guys
are here for
you know we we are we're 43 minutes into
the podcast and we're going to talk
about
Starfield under attack question mark
under attack all right so what how Rules
of Engagement dart rules of engagement
we're not only talking about
uh we're not only talking about star
filled post launch we're talking about
up toe launch
we're talking about you know uh the the
little things that they did to try to
attack it we're talking about who did it
because I think there's some fan sites
that are just going at it crazy there's
websites going at it crazy
we'll talk about it all I'm Gonna Let
You Go first there
hit it
you know my last video was about this
topic right here
I said PlayStation Fanboys and whoever
else they failed they failed they tried
their best to to make this game uh a
failure
from the from the smear campaign from
the beginning
before the game even released like you
just mentioned they were bashing the
game weeks ago they were bashing the
footage from E3 this year bashing the
footage from last year they were doing
analysis videos talking about this
talking about that
why can't I go on this planet it's ha
Howard live they tried their best to
destroy the game before it released and
there's only one reason
they did this
because zenimax is now owned by Xbox
but there's the games have been coming
out for years have you ever heard a
smear campaign on the Bethesda game
before released tell them dirt
I haven't
it's only one reason they're doing this
get a dirt yeah these poses
and it's sad because you know Phil
Spencer knew the scrutiny that comes
with being under Xbox that's why Phil
expensive gave him another year
policies game as much as possible we
give you guys another year because he
knew just being Xbox first party people
will be going crazy and I have never
seen
the amount of hate this game is getting
let me take that back even before the
game released
I can't think of a game getting this
much hate like damn
a studio that's known for having
I wouldn't say polish or quality games
but they their games damn sure get high
Metacritic scores their previous games
get nominated for Game of the Year some
have one game of the year a game like
Elder Scrolls got like well a 96
Metacritic
something like that some high 90s
but because this game is a
Xbox first party title
see all of this crap man
all of this crap
uh invisible walls attic
I'm going to run 40 minutes in One
Direction
fake it act like it's 10 minutes
and I'm going to run into an invisible
wall then I'm going to say tah Howard
lied
or
I'm gonna get mad because can't plan on
a gas plant
the gas planet I'm calling that right
now gas gate
and and these guys
say why am I running into an invisible
wall after running 40 minutes
in our Direction
then the same people would say I can't
land on a gas planet people say no
you're not you can't land on gas planets
you idiot then they say well it's a
video game
oh so it's a video game where you want
to walk on the Sun and land on gas
planets but it's not a video game when
you run into an invisible wall
make up your mind is it a video game or
not because you want to do one thing
that's not realistic but the other thing
that's not realistic you're criticizing
them
I hate them all addict I'm sorry go
ahead bro I hate them look I will say
that you know first off and they this
game is not 84. it's just not you know I
would say
8788 is where I would put this and I get
it
the the problem that I can't stand is a
lot of people are trying to make this
game other things they're like oh I I
played this I I didn't expect you know
up a Thursday game oh I played this I
expected them to do something different
oh I played this because it's a you know
I saw Astra cross's review and I respect
that dude you know I did and he started
bringing up stuff that I wasn't really
considering so I was giving him the bin
for the doubt and he's still a cool dude
like I really respect I don't know if
you know who he is he's a destiny
content creator and he he made a star
foot review and
as much as I respect his review and his
opinion on Star film
he compared it to Star uh to Destiny a
bunch of times like oh you know this
isn't this isn't the kind of gameplay
that I want I want more fluid game play
than this
yeah but you're playing literally one of
the most
one of the most
uh which I'm looking for fluid gameplay
with first person that's ever existed
you can't compare
Bungie's Foundation to anything because
they're second to none for the most part
and I get it like I do get it to a point
I I do get it to a point it's like you
know some of the other stuff he was
doing
I was all right you know I feel you on
that I feel you on that you know some of
the other things I was like
that that's that's
that makes sense you know I get it I get
it but it's just like some of the things
it was just like
can we can we compare
this game to this game please like can
we compare Starfield to Starfield now he
was talking about like certain things
that like Oblivion did that Starfield
didn't do that's fair criticism it's
just like but you can't compare
Starfield
star Phil
to Bungie
because because it's just like you know
I do agree with him that
a lot of the
a lot of the dialogue could have been
improved a lot more green perfectly
valid uh you know criticism
so besides him because I do think he's
coming from a genuine place he's coming
from a place that he wanted this game to
be good where I draw the line is when I
see people
constantly looking for bad stuff they
did it's like they went into the game
looking for bad stuff and if you go into
a game with the intentions of [__]
on that game you'll be surprised at how
bad you can find stuff how much a
negative negativity you can find about a
game I could go into Spider-Man right
now and find you mad stuff that's on
that that doesn't make sense and what's
funny is I bet you I could find a
barrier oh absolutely and 100 percent
like you say if you're looking for it
you know you're gonna find it so I'm not
getting the cat I don't know where the
cat went
I said people wanted to see this Alex
cat opinions
what's your opinion huh what's your
opinion
you're gonna talk
oh now you're not now you're too shy
you're not gonna talk
yeah man um it's it's crazy to compare
Destiny to a game like
Starfield come on man stop it
stop I just you know but this is going
to show you we predicted this we
most Xbox fans saw this coming we saw
the hey you know it's funny when you for
years say Xbox has no games at all
you laugh at Xbox lack of games you say
all they have is Halo gears and Forza
but when Xbox actually has a new IP
first you guys said it's not Xbox game
um because it's any Match Game and
everybody knows that Xbox help helped
um they they actually assisted zenimax
Bethesda in getting this game out
they absolutely help them
but they said first they said it's not
Xbox game
then rare fog came out then they say oh
but there's the games all Xbox games
then when they said okay this is this is
the Xbox game then they went on a hate
campaign before the game even released
then after the game release oh
when we started to hear positive Xbox
numbers PC numbers
Early Access the game is actually
selling sold 2 million plus before the
game officially released then they have
these oh well God of War so five million
well well Fallout 4 ship 12 million back
in 2015. how about that uh this is a
failure then people say well this game
is a failure then Xbox and Genie mass
comes out and say we have six million
players
well okay that's six million but it
still ain't still like Fallout 4 now
you're comparing to Zenni Max Games you
know it was it's just a mess man it's
just a mess
yeah and plus there was two million
people paying extra just to play that
game early yep
and you got a little think about the
Game Pass people I had the review copies
of this they there was people and I I
don't know if you were one of them
they paid thirty dollars just yeah I was
one of them one of them imagine that
I was wondering we already got Game Pass
Microsoft whoever whoever thought of
it's a genius yo you know we're not
giving them the game
let's charge them thirty dollars just to
upgrade to the premium stuff you know
they don't get the game they just get it
played early you see if I if I didn't
get the review copy I would have been
right there with you guys because there
ain't no way I'm waiting seven days
right it's not happening yeah it's just
it's it's so cool because regardless if
this got game got an 84 and that's a
tragedy travesty like it really is like
you know I was okay with it being at 87.
yeah I thought that was fair there's a
lot of issues with the game I was even a
little okay for 86. but then when I
started seeing people give it a 4 out of
10 and a 5 out of 10. ridiculous 6 out
of ten for no reason read the reviews it
makes no sense but it's like they didn't
even play the game yeah they were
someone that literally gave it a six out
of ten and didn't even that played six
hours of it
six
are you gonna sit here you're gonna tell
me with a straight face that people
actually played large amounts of that I
don't think they did I didn't I think a
lot of these sites that didn't get their
codes
I think they took this as a opportunity
to get back at Bethesda for for not
giving them early hours oh they said uh
I believe Metro UK
said what they were going to give it
before they played they said I was gonna
give it a six out of ten a troop song
This truth serum just said something I
forgot to mention
when Phil Spencer himself came out there
and said we've had one million plus
concurrent players
people said ah that ain't nothing like
do you know what concurrent means buddy
those are Peak Halo 3 numbers addict one
million concurrent players
come on man
come on let's try their best to down
please bro it's crazy man like
it's just like can we just please just
keep
faith
can we just please be honest that's all
my thing like if you're gonna give the
game a 7 out of 10 and I generally think
you're gonna get like that's genuine
that that's that's from the heart you
know I just didn't like ask your cross I
watch his review even though I disagreed
with certain comparisons he made I know
Astra cross as an influencer
I know him as a walk like I've watched
his content as well for for years I know
that's his his actual opinion there's no
political thing being dragged on there
there's no gaming politics being dragged
on there there's no spite being dragged
on there he just didn't like Starfield
and that's okay
but what I don't like is people using
the Metacritic score to manipulate and
send a message because we should be you
we should be looking at the Metacritic
score as like a high tier thing it
should be a sacred process that we want
to make sure is is straight narrow this
isn't the and I've said this before this
isn't the issues of of the I don't know
if we talked about this last week but
this isn't an issue with the people
doing it's an issue of Metacritic
obviously these people know that giving
a game a 4 out of 10 to get
to get some quick clicks quick clicks
why would you not do that you know it's
you know your morals are wrong and your
integrity is a little questionable
but some of these companies they
probably don't have a choice
they probably struggle in financially
they're trying to make sure they're
trying to make sure that they don't got
to lay people off
so I see it to a point yeah but it's
just like why is Metacritic letting them
do that why is it still that you that
five out of five games are Metacritic
just screws up the whole engine on
Metacritic and they haven't reached out
to these five out of five people it said
you either change your review process to
a 10 out of 10 scale or you're off
Metacritic
how many of these companies if they were
hit with an automator like that would
would fight them
very few right they okay I'm switching
almost immediately
and they have the power to do that but
it's like they don't it's like they
don't care so you don't care about your
own platform
it's ridiculous man
it's ridiculous so
um I agree with that but you know
from the the console war standpoint you
know the Metacritic score is nothing but
uh bragging rights that's all it is
right and to be honest with you the
PlayStation Fanboys started it last
generation you know because Xbox had a
few games that didn't do so well the
Metacritic and they let Xbox people know
Crackdown with the 50 meanwhile God of
War has a 92 whatever God will had and
you know PlayStation got great
Metacritic scores and last generation
Xbox struggled but this generation
they're doing much better
it's funny it's funny how
uh State of Decay sea of Thieves uh
Crackdown 3 got bad meta created scores
right 60 55 that's terrible Xbox has no
quality games
but then when Xbox game Starfield got a
this is the bad metal credit score too
like what how was 87 the bad Metacritic
score now it's down to 84 they still oh
it's even worse it's dropping okay so a
60 is a abysmal better credit score but
now a 87 is a and the business credit
score also I don't get it
it makes no sense
it is what it is at that point man it's
like you know there there's nothing that
we can do to to fix that you know
PlayStation Fanboys they can go at it as
much as they want
it is what it is at that point and you
know
I hate that for them but we're gonna go
move on to like right like because we've
had starford a little bit time to digest
and I thought it was really important
for us to be able to just sit on the
Starfield talk for a little bit
uh so what I want to talk about is just
you know overall Impressions that you
have after playing it for a little bit
more time I I also want to talk to you
about you know these things these mods
that we're seeing I want to I want to
have a good conversation about as well
as I see like you know they're putting
uh field of view on their fov sliders on
the PC I don't know if that's on Xbox
yet and it's just like do you think that
these things should have been involved
day one do you think that it was a
mistake to hold these features back
because I think that's one of the
reasons that the game didn't do the
greatest on PC like in terms of you know
Metacritic because PC people are very
very entitled for a reason because they
have so many settings they pay all this
money for their console for their PC so
I can understand one of these settings
and the fact that Bethesda a primary PC
manufacturer or software developer
didn't have these options what do you
think yeah I mean I guess if you want to
talk about the PC cry out yes maybe they
should have had those options available
for the PC crowd because like you said
they're really picky um they want stuff
how they want it so yeah maybe they
should have had that prepared but at the
same time this is the day we're living
in bruh
people can sit here and say this and
this and that oh no these games are
finished are all like released
unfinished and unfortunately that's the
time we live in
it is so for them to add a few things uh
a couple weeks later cool
no when you think it's only been a
couple weeks it should have been their
launch yeah probably but it is what it
is man you know you look at again like
Star Wars Jedi Survivor
that game just got another big update to
to you know to make the 60 FPS a little
bit more stable the game been out for
like six seven months now
so oh but everything good
as I said big mad MO
already in Indy showcase I thought that
was the first one so this is a secret
show yeah that's right big bad Mo yeah
man we're not gonna really talk about
that because uh yeah I I was going to
talk about it on the show but then I saw
the expectations for the show I just
want them to show Stellar yams Stellar
buns Stellar buns Stellar buns and I'll
be happy those robot cheeks yeah you
know I just had a PlayStation fan but I
made a joke on Twitter I said so is this
that second uh that secret that real you
know because I don't know if you know
you don't do the console war stuff too
much I know you're aware of certain
things but there was some PlayStation
Fanboys saying that the first Showcase
in May which was abysmal they were
saying that that wasn't that wasn't the
real showcase PlayStation is going to
have a another showcase this month
September that's going to be the real
the real showcase that's the real real
showcase the real showcase show I went
on Twitter after this stated play was
announced and I said is this the real
the real showcase that PlayStation
Fanboys told us about and I had a
PlayStation Fanboy he is definitely
going to be POS of the week
he uh he said yes this is uh no they're
going to have the state of play but
they're going to do the real Showcase in
October
I said damn bro
so you're saying this state of play is
what it is but they're going to have a
Showcase in October is that what you're
telling me and he doubled down on it
so tell me
a map
I couldn't begin
to describe to you
how much King
probably was failing when he saw that
like because because I think we're gonna
live stream it tomorrow are you doing a
live stream no no no I'll talk about it
afterwards because I go live at six and
I think it starts at five so it'll be
right right after well good I'll I'll
send our people to you okay cool perfect
yeah because it
[Laughter]
yo
put it with one in the chat if you think
Nintendo's gonna smash
PlayStations direct tomorrow because
they're both the same day yeah Nintendo
is going to smash what time is
Nintendo's do you know it is like nine
in the morning if you're okay I think
it's like 10 or 7 in the morning if
you're on Pacific and right nine
it I hope they're both good I really do
I hope they're both good but it's just
like
no
just don't get it man like where where's
placed
we gotta talk about dirt
is PlayStation back on their PS3 energy
[Laughter]
um I'm not sure I will say this
I would say this
there well you know they might be back
on their PS3 energy because right now
they are still relying on the casuals
choosing the PS5 so far this generation
yes they had a couple of uh exclusives
they had a few they had more than Xbox
um or Triple A that's to say but those
games were PS4 games
first party is you know it's by even but
they had a lot of third-party deals and
I'll give props to gas cause gas said
was it yesterday or two days ago
oh no I'm sorry last week he said
PlayStation's first party looks like
[__]
and their first party road map we have
Spider-Man
Wolverine eventually
a couple of live service games and we
know nothing yes I understand that
Circle punch is working on product but
probably goes to sushima too
but who knows what else is going on
and that road map is looking spooky bro
I don't care what nobody's saying Xbox
world map is looking spectacular
and there's still a lot of unannounced
games from XBox Camp so
I think they're real they're relying on
the casuals at this moment because the
cows was have chosen the PS5 so far
but we'll see what happens man because I
don't know if you saw earlier uh you
know Starfield actually moved some Xbox
consoles in the UK did you see that
yeah I actually made a video about that
oh did you did the drop yeah and if it's
UK you know you know uh the the states
they they did either on par better yeah
hey TJ Jazz oh gas was kind of talking
trash before that PlayStation showcase
you know guys the home for he was like
they're gonna destroy that's why I was
like oh shoot
but you know listen it is what it is now
because uh that definitely didn't happen
so he was saying you're at a road map
looking sus man
yeah I guess to me
my biggest thing is I just
I just want to see what PlayStation is
doing after Spider-Man and Wolverine
like to me it just looks like a bunch of
you know games as a service from
Spider-Man Wolverine yeah we keep
hearing all these other studios are
making
like uh I remember
Horizon devs supposedly they they're
making like a multiplayer type of thing
yeah yeah so that's like confirmed is it
is it tagged on with the Horizon team
or is this going to be
the way they go from now on because I
I'm just curious on that you know it
it is it is what it is when it comes to
that
right now Dirk's doing something oh
smash back over when he's done I just
want guys I I want things to go good
like I do you know and I feel
that PlayStations lost its way you know
I think they're seeing the fortnite
money they're seeing all this money go
up and they want that
because if you look at it they're
spending money
it's just not in in studios it's not in
single player games
it's anime because they bought
FUNimation and they bought Crunchyroll
uh they just recently bought something
else I just can't remember what it was
oh it was this oh yeah yeah like the
headphone yeah the headphone uh they
they have bought multiple Studios to do
live service games
I just don't see the same energy these
days being thrown into you know what
made them unique and what made them
popular now that might just be because
you know why would they have to come out
openly and talk about these things
because we know they're there it's just
it is one of those things when it comes
to that man yeah I'm going to ask you
one question before we go
PlayStation 4 was a very successful
console did great right
um
why do you think they changed their
strategy at it
they went from great single player games
to totally changing their strategy
completely to having a couple single
player games
and games as a service
why do you think they changed their
strategy
uh
I think it's just
they're like yo this single player money
good
but that for my money over there looking
real nice I think that's literally what
it is yeah yeah I will get to the super
chats here in a second guys don't worry
um I just I think that's literally what
it is it's
we like this money
but this money's letting us buy some
food some buildings that money's letting
us buy some Yachts um
you know it's like King said Jim's
trying to get a yacht
he's tired of Phil being the only one
with a yacht
trying to get a y'all yeah I um I agree
you know I said and like me and my homie
Sean said it's just not sustainable
anymore
the single player only
uh strategy isn't sustainable anymore
because PlayStation has some quality
single player games don't get me wrong
but those games are quality and they are
also expensive
and Jim Ryan himself said selling 10 to
20 million isn't cutting it anymore when
you think about a game like The Last of
Us cost 200 something million to make
and it sells 10 million I mean 10
million is great
but
I'm saying man you know I don't know
they're changing their strategy so we'll
see what happened bro
yeah I I feel it'll be good though you
know let me get these super chats real
quick two dollar Super Chat for angry
therapists MD oh God I worked too hard
for her addict talking about talking
about Sarah we got a member chat for
five months from God Emperor Sofa King
imagine being hyped for a state of play
focusing on Indies and third-party could
not be me PlayStation fans are desperate
to be honest with you I understand
that's a joke but I don't know about uh
dirt sorry I didn't put those on the
screen uh I guess I can go back up if I
could see it
uh so to me I guess like when it comes
to me is I just get hyped for any kind
of game thing it doesn't matter what it
is uh you know obviously there's gonna
be some clowning going on as well but I
just I just like the events anyway like
I like it the ideal that any moment I
can get like swept off my feet I know
that sounds like a really like like
cringe thing to say but I really do I
like at any moment it's just gonna be
something that's really going to
Captivate me and be really good you know
thing to watch I can't find one of your
guyses and I apologize for that so we're
going to start with um that one and then
we'll go to this one
now you're gonna you'll probably laugh
at this one
uh five dollars for God Emperor suffer
King Dreamcast guys face looks like a
ghoul from Fallout
oh my God
like
I got no issue with Dreamcast guy but
what I will say
is
his content I'm just like
like scratching my head these days yeah
like it is what it is you know I'm not
saying the dude pulls any type of like
imma do this this day I'm gonna do this
that day
but it just to me it's just like
do do you even like games like I don't
know like maybe he just didn't like Star
Phil I mean we won't go too much on that
but I just get frustrated man and I know
that's not like Drake ass guys fall or
anyone else's fault it's just I see it
so often now I assume everyone's doing
it
and and it's just like
it is what it is at this point but you
know if he is
if he is or not click baiting every uh
video and he's making Mad Money
but then you know
I guess yeah
because trust me like
that money nice
you know I've been pretty good keeping
myself out of those those corners but
I'm not getting the type of viewership
that he gets either
so I don't know you know it is what it
is when it comes to that so Dart before
we head out of here what what what
you've been playing man what what is
what are you hopeful for like I see
people talk about lies of p is that
something you're interested in what do
you want to play
I'm not really into the souls games like
that but I'll damn sure download it and
give it a chance you know I'm saying
just like I did with wulong like one was
pretty decent I just don't like Souls
games like that
um so yeah it was uh you know
um so yeah I've been playing you know
like I said Starfield of course 2K I'm
definitely going to play Mortal Kombat
winning drops
um I'm looking forward to that so that's
about it brother
that's what's up and you know I think
I'm looking forward to Liza P I'm
playing the crew right now it's pretty
much a copy and paste for her from
Horizon but is it we got to be real
though are they really that stupid
like if you see something like Horizon
doing really well yeah wouldn't you take
it upon yourself to be like okay
maybe I do need to do this you know what
I'm saying like it it's just one of
those things or it's like if it's
working so well why not do it yeah and I
can't really blame them on that one I
can't really play them on that one
yeah that's about it so you got to check
out my channel when you get a chance
if you prefer Xbox
yeah so right there man we we got I'm
gonna I'm gonna highlight right there
man go go to my my my dudes Channel man
go over there to to Dirk's Channel
follow him you should put your Twitter
in there too oh yeah
always always forget to put my Twitter
on there I guess because I don't tweet
that often
but I do tweet like you know when I
promoting my shows or whatever that's
only I mean I've been trying to do a
little bit more better like tweeting in
general
um uh because I do realize that that's
like an important thing absolutely
because uh you know those Twitter
followers can you know really
get you in front of people especially
the way Elon like and plus I don't know
how elon's gonna like long like
long-term wise do stuff
uh so I gotta automatically assume that
he's gonna make it really probable for
us to to monetize that I should tweet my
only fans I do not have the only thing
you guys are funny
uh let me see what we can send you guys
to
because uh
Fame is not live yet unfortunately you
know what I mess with this dude you guys
might not like this dude but I like him
uh player Essence over there at uh
spawn wave definitely go over there and
tell them addicts uh tell attic show
you know attic raid or whatever you guys
want to say even if you go in there and
just say man just say addict sent you
yeah because because he's a good dude
man you know very passionate Nintendo
follower I'm sure Nintendo Dawn the
otaku is killing that one just go in
there for me a personal favorite of me
man say attic sent you man uh but you
know like I said follow us on our social
medias and uh we'll see you next week
man we'll see you next time yo
peace peace out remember go over there
and say addict sent you it's very
important
add Accenture